and finally new rule never forget that
the man who promised we would win so
much that we'd get tired of winning just
lost an entire country forget for a
moment the ethnic cleansing and the
double crossing of an ally and let's
just focus tonight on the long-held
Republican obsession with just not
losing because that used to be kind of a
big thing you couldn't lose a country
the John Birch Society was named after a
missionary who was the first casualty
when we lost China FDR was vilified
because he lost Eastern Europe Truman
lost Korea Obama lost Libya and Hillary
of course lost Wisconsin but
that was it American didn't lose
countries and then a few weeks ago
Vladimir Putin had a birthday and as a
present Trump gave him Syria
which is fair since in 2016
Trump gave Putin gave Trump America but
but again I seem to vaguely remember
when Republicans were against gifting
countries to the Russians but then I
also remember when they were against
tariffs deficits in adultery
I even remember when the Republicans
used to like the FBI simpler times
did you know Eisenhower was against
Nazis it's true we like to talk in
America about president's having
doctrines in foreign policy JFK was
pretty clear about his doctrine in 1961
he said we shall pay any price bear any
burden meet any hardship support any
friend oppose any foe in order to assure
the success of Liberty and now we know
the Trump doctrine I wish them all a lot
of luck Russia wants to get involved
with the with Syria that's really up to
them well that's one way to work with
the Kremlin but you really wouldn't call
it containment this is how Republicans
contest whether your devotion to Trump
has passed into the realm of the
irrational if Trump hands Syria over to
Russia and Iran to nations you've spent
the last 50 years calling evil and
you're suddenly good with it well the
results are in and I'm sorry you've
tested positive for cult
because since the end of World War two
the Republican Party has been pretty
consistent about one message that we're
the national security tough guys these
colors don't run and then Trump ran from
Syria like he owed it money we fought
side by side with two million Kurds and
then one morning Trump tells them lose
my number
complete with the walk of shame
footage you see that we left Syria
barefoot in a torn dress pelted with
rotten potatoes by the betrayed locals
if Obama did this the headline on Fox
News would be Muslim to fellow Muslims
here have some more caliphate
Obama took a lot of heat for how he
handled Syria he didn't enforce the red
line he was leading from behind he
backed the wrong militia but he didn't
just flat-out lose it you think that
would be at least as big a deal to trey
gowdy as the consulate in benghazi louie
gohmert couldn't tell Benghazi from
bengay but when Democrats lost it
Republicans reacted like the Japanese
bombed Graceland
they held they held six investigations
that dragged on for three years Fox News
did over a thousand stories suggesting
that Hillary either [ __ ] it up covered
it up ordered it or killed our troops
personally by hand when Obama wanted to
release a small number of Guantanamo Bay
prisoners Republicans went pink Chicken
Little even the prisoners we tortured so
much that they could only babble
incoherently like Giuliani on Fox News
we couldn't send them back but when
hundreds of Isis prisoners get out Trump
says well
they'll be escaping to Europe yeah [ __ ]
Europe it's not like they're our allies
or anything Democrats you can't make
more of an issue out of this geez the
divide between what is okay for
Republicans to do versus what is okay
for Democrats it's just so out of hand
now there's always this double standard
Republicans can lose countries Democrats
can Democrats have to say how how
they're gonna pay for stuff Republicans
just put it on the card
a Republican could pay hush money to a
pornstar or run for Senate and Alabama
as an accused child molester but a
Democrat can't get caught with a woman
even if she is a woman
you